thomas vous vous situez donc sur l'un
des nombreux lieux choisis par les
agriculteurs pour manifester ce matin
quelle est l'ambiance sur place
eh bien écoutez grégory je vais vous
montrer concrètement comment se passe
cette action vous avez en fait trois
rangées de tracteurs qui sont
actuellement stationnés ici sur cette
nationale 12 en direction de paris et
conséquence immédiate
aucune voiture donc sur cette voie en
fait les voitures sont obligés
d'emprunter la bretelle de sortie en
direction de la station service pour
finalement accéder à la capitale
il s'agit pour les agriculteurs de ne
pas trop impacter les automobilistes
mais en même temps de faire entendre
leurs revendications des revendications
qui sont assez nombreuses et qui porte
ce principalement sur cette réforme de
la politique agricole commune qui est en
pourparlers à bruxelles certains nous
explique que cette modification cette
réforme pourrait avoir des conséquences
très concrètes pour eux par exemple il
pourrait perdre jusqu'à 80 euros par
hectare parce que les aides et
subventions qu'ils reçoivent pourrait
être soumise à des conditions notamment
environnementales et ils n'ont pas
forcément les moyens ou le temps de
faire évoluer leurs exploitations
agricoles pour répondre justement à ces
critères environnementaux je vous
propose d'écouter un agriculteur
d'eure-et-loir c'est le département
voisin ici des yvelines il s'exprime au
micro de renault parquet qu'un fils qui
aujourd'hui a fait des études agricoles
il ingénieur agricole et ils travaillent
à l'extérieur
je donne un exemple tout à l'heure mon
père dans les années 65
ils étaient trois sur l'exploitation ma
grand mère mon grand père et mon père
190 ha aujourd'hui j'ai 230 hectares et
je suis loin de de gagner ce que mon
père et mon grand-père on pouvait gagner
à cette époque là donc c'est pas normal
je devrai monfils accepte surface là
devrait revenir sur la ferme sans
problème et aujourd'hui il ne peut pas
revenir et j'ai ma femme qui travaille à
l'extérieur et bamert travaillais déjà
l'extérieur ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'il faut pas oublier en france il n'y
a pas que des bonnes terres il n'y a pas
que des bonnes prairie ya pas que des
bonnes voilà il ya des des zones qui
sont plus ou moins à faible potentiel et
ça faut aussi en tenir compte
il faut aider les agriculteurs dans sa
laideur f1 pour ça qu'on parle aussi de
terme en zone intermédiaire
un qui ont besoin d'un coup de main
supplémentaire vous l'avez entendu
certains agriculteurs sont déjà plongés
dans un désarroi parce que les
conditions sont évidemment déjà très
compliqué pour eux et j'en appelle donc
au président de la république a
d'ailleurs une banderole qui a été
affichée non loin d'ici qui dit macron
répond nous en attendant il ya un député
le député modem des yvelines bruno myle
yen qui est venu à la rencontre des
agriculteurs ici ce matin pour échanger
avec eux sur leurs revendications il
fait parti de la majorité présidentielle
on l'a interrogé justement sur cette
concurrence déloyale que dénoncent les
agriculteurs qui sont donc mis en
concurrence avec des agriculteurs
d'autres pays européens qui n'ont pas
forcément les mêmes normes que et aussi
des agriculteurs de pays comme le canada
ou le brésil des pays avec lesquels la
france a signé des traités de libre
échange et là encore c'est une forme de
concurrence
écouter les réponses de bruno myle yen à
ce sujet ce qui est important surtout
c'est de voir leurs revendications alors
évidemment tout le monde on est en
pleines négociations de la pac on est en
pleine finalisation de la stratégie
nationale que le mini julien normandie
va porter à bruxelles
donc c'est important d'aller sur le
terrain de voir leurs problématiques et
de remonter aux ministres tous les
points qui leur semble délicat où
compliqué de manière à ce qu'on arrive à
trouver un terrain d'entente entre le
ministère et les agriculteurs c'est
important on le sait la ferme france va
mal elle est en train de mourir et nous
on a envie de la sauver bon le ceta a
été voté moi je n'ai pas voté le 7 à
pour être honnête tout en reconnaissant
que de tous les accords internationaux
qu'on ait eue c'était sûrement le plus
vertueux mais le plusieurs tu veux pas
dire qui nous conviennent totalement et
moi il ne convenait pas notamment en
matière agricole
bon ça c'est un ça c'est un point il a
eu une influence bénéfique au canada
quand même malgré tout parce que on leur
a dit que sur les produits agricoles
on allait vérifier quand même les
données et que si les normes n'étaient
pas compatibles ça ne marcherait pas
alors c'est un tout petit influence pour
l'instant c'est un début mais il ya des
agriculteurs des éleveurs bovins au
canada qu'on changé leur façon d'élever
dauvin pour se rapprocher de la façon
dont on le fait en france donc si à
chaque fois qu'on est dur dans les
échanges internationaux sur nos normes à
nous en disant si vous n'appliquez pas
nos normes
vous ne rentrez pas ça obligera
forcément les pays à bouger aussi
voilà donc pour cette action menée ici
par la fnsea et par les jeunes
agriculteurs d'île de france notamment
il ya au total plus d'une dizaine
d'actions qui sont en train d'être en ce
moment en train d'être fait par don en
ce moment en région parisienne si ça ne
devait pas aboutir certains nous
explique ici qu'ils sont prêts à mener
d'autres actions pour finalement se
faire entendre par le gouvernement dans
le cadre donc de ces pourparlers de la
nouvelle politique agricole
merci thomas bonnet pour toutes ces
précisions en direct donc de houdan dans
les yvelines en région parisienne